one of my favorite people who I've
gotten to know and meet over the last
several years I mean whose job is in
anyway it's hers basically thank you so
much
criminal minds whose line is it anyway
which you're gonna be hosting for a
seventh season tenth season of Archer
season finale is tomorrow night at 10:00
p.m. Eastern and Pacific on FXX
Archer 1999's I should Tollywood I was
out of the country for two months just
got back two weeks ago went straight to
comic-con I slept like 3 hours a night
then Oh straight to New York to work
slept three hours a night yes just I'm a
ghost that's a ghost the same as you are
you're getting the last you're getting
the last 2% of my battery right so it's
basically the newest show of Aisha Tyler
hopped up on codeine its audience right
here blasting through your phone's but I
did bring you a present because I'm a
brand new line of cocktails launching
right now virgin stone you know for the
discerning adult person who doesn't want
to drink a sparkly you know kind of
cooler tight beverage it's an adult
beverage yes um it's ready to drink you
don't add anything it's 80 proof so it's
as strong as a straight whiskey so
you're getting value for your buck and
if you want to come home and have a nice
drink you don't make it you just pour it
okay have you brought glasses I brought
two with ice because I am a grown and so
this is our old fashioned
this is a this is a new this is a new
venture here I would say it's five
o'clock somewhere and God bless Dom
Bowie are courting producer he let me
know it is five o'clock and Cape Verde
oh I guarantee no one knows where that
is until they google it enjoy googling
Cape Verde by the way that was the worst
in Euro movie ever by the way there we
go
a garnish what is this garnish this is
impressive it's a drag what very good
such a dried orange slice Cheers and
this is courage and stoned , so you can
get this line of premium blended bottle
cocktails so what do you do it's yours
cheers me
okay but you know the old fashion is the
most popular cocktail in the country
Thanks
it knows my part to madmen that's got a
kick right yeah well cause it's whiskey
take for the dried orange garnish -
actually it's just with this it doesn't
it doesn't
no it's just decorative decorative I'm
trying to class this place up every time
I come I want to add a little bit of
value decorative right now is the inside
of my esophagus no what I am NOT a big
whiskey drinking your maraschino cherry
[Laughter]
I always used to in diners I used to get
like the the cherry yeah for a drink and
I'd always used to eat those okay so
it's a classical fashion the whiskey is
small-batch distilled in Brooklyn by a
bunch of guys with beards and stuff and
actually the first batch
what is that no Brooklyn guys have
Brooklyn like to wear beards okay this
first batch of curtain stone we talked
about it being crafted I actually
bottled the very first myself before
people didn't know know that my peoples
literally did was just in New York I was
what I was doing in here what's with the
name what's the origin of the name um
originally I was thinking something
along the lines of liquid courage yes
and and I wanted it to sound like
something that had some Providence and
some strength that kind of spoke to like
the American idea of self starter ship
and craftsmanship sure and I just took
courage and lined it up with a lot of
other words until I found two I liked
and then I asked my friends what they
like the best
origins grouping at its cheapest guys
just get your friends drunk and ask him
which one they what they like you know
it sounds like the American West and
pioneers it does and and it also looks
like you need to make sure that it's not
next to the I guess perfume or something
like but you know this is there's like a
very very nice flask sighs Bobby's party
or a tailgate yo
your friends are drinking some kind of
bottom of the cooler beer and you're
like guys I just got a promotion to a
better cocktail you know whatever you
how are we smack talking a tailgating if
you're not making fun of the friends at
a tailgate that's true you're doing it
wrong you are doing it wrong 90% of
tailgating is insulting your friends 10%
is screaming about the fact that your
team is Lisa I you should Tyler right
here on the Rich Eisen show what else it
looks like you have jams it's like you
know way of serving an old fashion is
with a cherry would you like a chair
yeah I mean come on now don't cheat me I
mean cherry expert apparently I am okay
now let's see if it's any better all
right this is by the way my third sip
before 11:30 in the morning Pacific okay
day drinking mark of an evolved adult
liquid lunch I because you are not my
mom by the way I could I could use this
during the Hall of Fame ceremony what's
the weather gonna be like during the
whole thing doesn't can't know how
usually it's about 90 degrees 100
percent humidity right there in
beautiful Stark County Ohio this
wouldn't be bad it wouldn't be bad and
we also made it because because it's 80
proof you can pour it over ice and it's
gonna hold its structure and its
flavorful alright your Saturday forecast
and Canton mostly sunny 84 degrees
how does it 61% human how does it pair
with a chick-fil-a sandwich well the
best way to drink a great cocktail is
with the most kind of like low like you
know like low-rent street food you know
burrito tacos like the fish sticks at
your mom for down the freezer and yours
dying to eat in the morning well not the
best calorie choice with could be them I
mean are we on it are we gonna dye it
are we living our lives here yes there
will be anywhere between six to eight
speeches on Saturday very long it's very
some of them are on average about 25-30
minutes oh gosh and you know many of
them are very moving and you know it's
not sometimes you just don't want to
check your watch keep this in your suit
pocket and then just a little a little
little pop lip little pops you know
that's that's it's the idea is quality
over quantity you know if I actually did
this
probably the worst thing would be to
Telegraph my decision to the entire free
world before I actually do that on the
NFL Network you have a bad poker face
two hotel or keep a secret
think so I mean III famous less or no
you know you're a poker player correct
like it was on the celebrities now have
you ever put Aisha Tyler on the Rich
Eisen show have you ever played in the
World Series of Poker did you do the
celebrity Poker Tour I never did the
series No give me time you need to come
a time to that lifestyle and I don't
have it but yeah I know I mean would you
now if you played in the World Series of
Poker would you do would you do the
sunglasses we can do what would you do
here respect to the insensitive sense
sensitivity this comment I would be like
the black lady Unabomber you wouldn't
know anything about me under there I'd
have like wrap arounds and a hoodie and
then another hoodie over that first
hoodie so you couldn't figure out where
the first one he came from that's the
way you would be yeah because I think
the problem is even the greatest poker
ever people are repetitive beings we
just developed tails and then when we
when we kill our old tails we develop
new ones right but if you could find a
way to kind of inhabit a different
character every time you pick poker yes
just pretend to be somebody else yes
that's another way to kind of mask your
tells well my problem is when I get
pocket aces mm-hmm I do get my heart
here's the worst telco for the joke I
now need an e ent right all right that's
too bad but comedy as you know it leaves
a mark so it does it does it because I'm
suffering my friends
so tell how much archers gonna return
for an all-new season in 2020 yes season
pick up which we're super yeah this is a
show that I never thought we'd get on
the air at all so the fact that we're
coming up on season 11 because it was
just too smart to dirty you need to kind
of thoughtful and literate so the fart
joke sale bro
you know just you tell me there's like
17 hours of The Bachelor on every single
night Oh be careful Oh somebody afraid
of the bachelor or the Bachelorette that
fellow right over there by the way thank
you they hit you in the face for the
help
he is he you live tweeted sometimes
great show it's fascinating television I
feel so sad for everyone involved on
this I do too but I can't stop watching
that's why he watch it amazing pathos
yeah trainwreck yeah the only one I
don't feel bad for is Chris Harrison no
cuz he's just swept away in his new
yacht on a river of contestants tears
that's a vivid image so I'm sorry as you
were saying about Archer next season
we're coming back we're going back to
conventional spy were conventional
espionage which we're excited about cuz
we said spent three seasons first you
know in a film noir in the 20s in Los
Angeles then we were on not [ __ ] island
but danger island and then we were in
space we're coming back to Terra Firma
okay that's fantastic whose line is it
anyway your seventh season it's such a
fun show guys are so talented and I get
to get in there with them and play games
and it's a blast it's just the best it
really is just how you know obviously
the improv aspect of it it's so it's so
difficult to do and people wonder like
is it scripted there are times when I've
forgot to host cuz my mouth is hanging
open cuz I'm like I know the guys didn't
know write the clue and they're just
incredible and I mean those guys are at
the top of their game there's nobody you
know in improv doing it better than they
are right I love it when people like man
I love that show whose line is anyway
they should bring that back I'm like
season 7 season seven you've had seven
years to Google whose line is it anyway
I feel the same way they should they
should bring back Criminal Minds that's
still on whatever happened to Criminal
Minds
Archer in whose line it is anyway anyway
how many years have you been on Criminal
Minds this is gonna be my fifth season
growing up and directing it directed a
bunch on that show and we shot we shot
season 15 we're done shooting it's
airing in January right and I'm now
moving on to almost full-time directing
I'm gonna be directing some shows on the
CW this fall and then I'm developing a
bunch of feature films so I'm going to
be mostly moving into
directing and drinking good for you yeah
at the same time yeah you've had so much
going on in your career I'd like to play
celebrity true or false with you is your
time ready here we go
oh okay you've got your courage and
stone for true or false I should tell
you graduated Dartmouth with a degree in
political science and a minor in
environmental policy that is true what
have you done with those I wasted four
years and not my parents money because I
couldn't afford it but a very very big
loan okay to become a professional clown
mmm so there's not a single moment where
your science and politics or any sort of
policy and have made it to your
environment any better other than angry
tweeting about the fact that we're all
about to obese deluge with seawater now
that's one so it is coming in is it true
you co-founded and sang in the Dartmouth
Rockefellers and all-female a cappella
groups spreading social awareness
through song that's a true story yes for
people don't understand exactly what
that means because it you know imagine
glee but like way less attractive people
like nobody really fit bad clothes yeah
yeah pitch in parable we could sing but
you know no dance numbers yeah did you
win a contest of any soil it was a
brand-new group and when I left I think
we won contest for like you know saddest
group of ladies in mock total mix but
after we left the group that remained
became incredibly well known traveled
the world without albums so it grew into
something really extraordinary okay
you appeared in Weird Al's music video
for the single tacky which is a parody
of Pharrell's happy is that a true story
I did and who Eric Stonestreet visited
Margaret Cho is in it it's a lot he just
called me just asked if I wanted to move
it yeah Oh Jack Black is in it he's
unbelievable it is this like number with
a fanny pack that is so you look down at
your phone this is weird al' in your
contact your doll is in my contacts okay
and i he says do you want to come do
this video or in store for free
afternoon on Sunday downtown and you
want to come look like an idiot and I
was like well that is my expertise well
I mean but he's weird out 25 million
views of this yeah it's a great view
it's really funny and you know
returned for him to his he hadn't done
something like this in a while it was a
return to his talking trade but it's a
really one continuous shot so we had to
do it a bunch of times cuz it's just one
kind of continuous drifting shot with
the Steadicam
for a lot of people who don't dance
professionally it's amazing we carried
it off but you need to watch it well of
course you need to watch it for me but
you also need to watch it for the Jack
Black performance which is extraordinary
okay
25 million people again 25 million views
last one your first onscreen credit was
a 1996 episode of Nash Bridges entitled
high impact did you remember the role
you played I was a news reporter it was
my very first job okay
I told my entire family hey I'm not as
dumb as you think I am I got a job on TV
grandma I proved you wrong and I'm sure
they're ready to watch it and they had
cut me out there I'm just in this one
like wide shot at the very end of this
big crowd
you have to like pause your VHS tape
because that's how long ago it was and
then like you know you can't zoom in but
look at like an eye loop and then press
it against your tube televisions were
you in the scene with Don Johnson I met
him but we did not have a scene together
and the thing I want to say right now I
can't say so that's the courage that's
the curse it's not covered in stone but
you played the role of reporter yes a
reporter a quote unquote report of a
reporter well it's all worked out from
there this game was just celebrity true
and true it's what your I guess so we
didn't come up with that well sometimes
this is stuff that we we will ask a
celebrity and it's all about
verification yeah they're all true all
right well I mean we'll come up with
more false ones for you the next time
I'd love it to be all false so I could
just deny that I went to the moon
Feuer on the moon are truly 1999 season
finale of season 10 it's tomorrow night
10:00 p.m. Eastern Pacific on FX X
courage and stone calm I can personally
attest that this thing packs a wallop
whose line is it anyway seventh season
coming up same with season 15 of
Criminal Minds it is great to see you
thank you for making it in here I know
you're trouble you know I'm glad I'm so
happy that I rallied I always love
coming to see you when I get rich is one
of my oldest Hollywood friends guys and
he's and I know that it doesn't feel
that way to you cuz he seemed everyday
but he's a great guy I appreciate really
great guy lovely delight that's the
courage for you to stay for one more
television only segment I have for
residual checks envelopes I'd like you
to pick one it will open one on the air
so excited I would love to know what you
what you know what what uh one sent
Chuck you've got it I used to Tyler you
can follow her on Twitter Instagram at
that that address as well courage and
stone calm spell out the word and to get
that web address great to see you you
got it when we come back here on the
show we we finish up with there is some
breaking news going on in the NFL I will
hit that when we come back here on the
Rich Eisen show all right back on the
Rich Eisen show Aisha Tyler sticking
around one more segment here I have in
my hands for residual checks that
arrived at my house recently I've been
opening my residual checks on television
I don't have as vast a filmography or
television ography as you do hit hit the
drop please Mike Dell to Fogo for us
[Music]
pay that man his money
so I get the question I have honestly
yes before we do this have you ever
opened a residual check where like you
know you you eyes got a big like Eddie
Murphy to come into America cuz you got
like a really big whoa recently I forgot
that I I sent in something to sag after
that I had not cashed a whole bunch of
small ones over two years and they
combined it for like eighty one bucks
I'm like whoa okay our definition of WoW
is very different I need to feel which
one it is
which one is it okay here we go you have
chosen envelope number three okay here
we go
what's this what was a what's your
residual check that you've got no one
said god you know what I did a movie
called dancing in September years and
years and years ago where I played
essentially the name of my character on
that movie was a woman with weave wasn't
my creative life at that time
yes and and yeah I've gotten some $0.08
checks and someone set checks from that
woman's weave okay here we go this is
from I'm sorry
this last one here we go
CSI Miami deep freeze yeah here we go
male educator oh yeah he's mad enough to
cover the ice in Rich's glass check out
Archer 1999 tomorrow night 10 p.m.
Eastern and Pacific on FXX for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under wreck TV for free on
BR live or download the Rich Eisen show
app